[Music]  president obama's campaign slogan for  2012 is forward they just announced that  it's going to be forward  and now  vice president joe biden is trying very  hard to come up with his own  slogan for the campaign he wants to have  one too and he doesn't want to be the  same in fact the other day the vice  president tried out several new slogans  all in the same speech not sure how it  went  your generation  is in the cusp of the most incredible  change in world history change only  comes through challenge i am more  optimistic about this country than i've  ever been in my whole life again not  because of barack and me  we can't do it  forget about your dignity forget about  all that  so why the hell don't you go home  get your parents to give you a loan  i don't quite get this  i'm so ashamed  all right i'm so ashamed  my favorite is i'm so ashamed  i would go with that right now everyone  can relate to it sure  i sure can